al
はいみなさんこんにちはええええ
映画監督の小泉の利用と申します今日はよろしくお願います
どう今日はどんな話ししようかなと思ったんですけどもまぁいい映画をテクニカんが話
をしてもちょっとあんまり
あの鉄球びっくりすぎるかと思ったんで
もうちょっと僕が高校の時に
これを知っておいて良かったなと思うことが一つは思い出したのでそのことを
直感せいかなと思っています
それは
なんで今勉強するべきなのかという
ことなんですね君たちはなぜ今勉強するべきかというタイプをつけさせていただきまし
た
8ですねまあなんで勉強するべきだって皆さん何か
ふと立ち止まって考えたことあるんでしょうか
なんとなく当たり前のようにやっていることだよ
何でこの子の里になるという
ちょっと思ったことがあるかないかまあわかりませんけども
たぶん何1徹甲意味じゃないと
思うんですよね
なんで
なんであるでしょうねぇ
みなさんきっとその難読将来の役に立つと思ってると思うんですけどもまぁすごく
なんでしょうね京王というところに入って
きっと厳しい
て受験勉強とかもしかし違うしないしね
もうすごく勉強皆さん大好きで超楽しいで障害と思うんですよ
もう将来生んだらいい大学行って
いいかシャ行って社会の役に立つんだって皆さんも熱いも思いをちょっと胸をたぎらせ
ていると思うんですけども
間違いなくでも
本当はちょっと面倒くさいと思ってると思うよね
本当は何でいく勉強したのかなちょっとわかってないところあると思うんです
この
アリオリ侍りとかサインコサインとかこれ本当に将来役に立つのかと
ぶっちゃけ疑問に思ったことないでしょうか
きっとあると思うんですよでも僕はの20年ぐらい皆さん先輩なんですけども
僕から言えることがですね
一つはっきりあってですね学校で
なかった勉強が将来にそうですね
役に立つことはありません
残念ながらないです
越冬青ご父兄の皆さんちょっとウジュン息子たちなんてことを吹き込むだと思ってるか
もしれないけどさ
私は最後は来ていただいてまあ役に立たないって言うよりはですね
役に立たせることができないですね
その皆さんが今学校で習ってることっていうのは物事の本当の処方的な
最初の入り口でしかないんですだからいきなりそれを持って
その知識を本邸社会に出て実戦に役立てようとまたもきっと皆さんはその方法がわから
ない
役に立たせる方法がわからないと思うんですよ
なんで
僕はあのー今映画監督という仕事をやってますけど僕の場合はどうだったっていう
阪神をしますとですねええ
まあかれこれ2210号館25グランド義母が映画監督になってですね
10年ぐらいになっておりますでそのキャンキャリア中で4位までをんかな
今後で撮ってきましたが学校の勉強が役に立ったことは1度もありません
一度もないです
役に立ったことは
あとへ僕が自分で勉強したことばっかり所へ
後になって映画のことを勉強し
得た知識で映画を作った
ですね
でも
パンッ
今4連投結構重要な事言ったんですけども
皆さん何足学生の間に
なんですよね学生時代が終わったらなぁ
便等から解放されるって思ってませんかね
もし社大学ついてちゃんになっても勉強しちゃっていいんだきっといい子だね行って
ホッとしてたりしないでしょうかそれはですねまあ明確に
んですね
犬 see
皆さんがそれでに勉強から解放されることはありません
皆さんは車外でたら
今以上にきっと勉強しなきゃいけなくなりますもっともっともっと持っ
と勉強しなきゃいけなかったと思う
きっとあの
1スロ大変ですでも
まあ心配することはそんなになくてですね
8ですね皆さんはまあ必要な勉強は必要ときに勉強すればいいです必要になったらその
勉強すればいい
だから心配することはありません
でもじゃあじゃあさじゃあなんで今勉強しなきゃいけない理由って機と思うと思うん
ですけども
僕は僕もそう思ってたんですよ僕も何て言いまべしゃっきやんだなーって思ってたん
ですけど
それに気づかせてくれたきっかけが一つあったんですね
それがこの人なんです
夏目そう
夏目漱石のこころっていう小説がありますね
それを皆さんもしかしたらもう無かったかもしれないし高校の間に多分なろうと思う
けどまぁ習ってないかもしれない人はまあこれからまだ部と思うんですけど僕は高校
本当にこれを
の授業でですね現代文だったかなこの授業で心という策について
えポー当確か
映画化するかどちらを選びなさいという課題が出たことがあったんです
その相応で伊勢市神です
でなんかれるほど通っていう男と女多彩なあって
思うじゃないですか
なんかいうのが楽しそうだし
絵が帰ってよくなったんですって軽い気持ちでやり始めたらもう断然でコードのかなと
だったんですけど
あとなんて考えていう
まあそれこそそこで映画作りっていうのを本当に何も知らないままやり始めたんですね
で
そこであの映画映画と語風に作ってるのか
自分で勉強して自分でいろいろやって来てやとそれが映画とかドラマとこういうふうに
作られてるんだな停車の方って自分でも作ることができるんだって思ったんですね
それでいっ
なんか映画作りをも集団
you fool 思うようになってですねで
こうして僕はあの紆余曲折を経て
映画監督になったんですけどもどうしてその今まで僕はその瞬間まで
映画づくりが面白い
思うことができなかったらそこに気付くことができなかったのは何故だっ
考えたらまあそれは当然ですよねやったことがなかったんです
映画を作るということをやったことはなかったからそれを面白いと思う
なかったそれまでよ
だから僕はこれを作ることによってなんていうか映画を見るもんじゃなくて
作るものだという視点を手に入れたんですね
作るという発想がそもそもなかったらに作りるってことが分かっ
そういう視点を
手に入れるものができたんですねでその時点から数えて正住不十分年後ぐらいつか
僕は wiki を消す特設を経てん映画監督
なりましたそしてその最新作もうちょっと宣伝本ずつ
あーこれなんですちょっとご覧なんてです
こんな感じで最初なくは今週ですね工場の土曜日3月19日から神の空か公開されて
4月29日からへ
下の句前後編ですね下の句が公開されます
え
累計発行部数が縦線600万部の第2キー漫画脳
方です競技かるたにかける高校生としたちゃ青春夢そして恋を描いた泣けるほどに熱い
青春映画になっています
寒天みました
もマンの原作だからって侮ってる人もいると思うんですけども
えっどうあなた載ってませんだきっとねこれけっこうこれ侮っちゃいけないんです
今回日本アカデミー賞を取った美馬時代よりも実は忘れがちですが漫画原作でしょうか
ね
じゃぜひぜひ以上でご覧いただければなと思っています
こんな子さん車はいまあそんなわけで越冬鵜川の5000
ときにそういう映画作りというものに出会うことができたんです
でこれだと思うので開いたんですけどもみなさんはどうでしょうかね
今これだってを心
私は勝利これをやりたいんだというものに出会えていますでしょうか
どうしたっ
まだであってる人いないような気がするんですよねきっとん
これから見つけられると思うんですけども
もしかして皆さんこれからやりたいこれゆえに気になるじゃなんだと思うからこれなん
じゃないでしょうかね
何でしょうかこれ
別れしていますか
これはですね a 10日は d というインドのスポーツんですね
皆さんこのカバーにクリスポーツしてますでしょうか
多分知らないと思うんです僕もしれません
僕もしれませんじゃあこれはどう打つ
これは競技かるたですねまあ先あの映画化したんで僕はして打つ手は競技かるたって皆
さん知ってます
何となく知っているけれどもとりあえず早く取ればいいんだろうぐらい後したと思い
ます
でもタイプといえばいいだけじゃんって中すごくたくさんは議論がルールがあったり
いろんなテクニックがあったりし
多く深い興味なんですけど皆さんたぶんこの
ルールとかあんまりよく知らないと思うのであのー競技かるたのかわいいもあるいは
カーリングとかルールを知らないと思うんですねだからそれを見てもきっと面白いと
思うことができないと思うんですよ
ルールを知らなければ誰でもどうでしょう野球とかサッカーをどうでしょうね
目3野球去った普段あんま見てないかも知れ見てる人多いと思いますが見てなくても
特に日本代表戦とかやったりするとなぜかしないよ925
国民性がアップして熱狂したりしません
なんとなく普段見てなくても分かるちゃうつスポーツのルールは
がゴールをボールにいればいいでしょうか今ベースを踏めばいいんですよねだいたい
わかるじゃないですよ
ながらじっと楽しみみることが良い
マラソンとか陸上競技も分かりやすいですね非常にゴールのばかり接しベルがわかる
だから皆さん普段見せなくてもなんとなく楽しむことができる
つまり
スポーツルールを知らないスポーツを見てて面白くないけどやっぱり何か楽しいと思う
ためにはある程度の知識が必要なんですよそれに対する
そうじゃないと面白いと思うことができないんです
だから皆さんは今勉強するべきなんです
それは皆さんがまだこれというものを見つけてないから面白いと思う
興味を持つ何かまだ見つけてないんだったらそれを見つけるためにある程度の知識を身
につけるため
皆さんは今勉強し
いけないそうするべきなんです
これからこれが最高に面白いと思う出会うためなんですそれが皆さんが今勉強するべき
理由です
そしてその
幅広い知識
浅く広いあるての知識を
簡単に効率的に短期間のうちに幅広く
そして
それをなんですかねなかば強制的
見つけられる場所身につけられる場所それはどこでしょうか
それは
ここなんです
学校なんですそうだったんです皆さんから面倒くせーと思ってる数学や物理や
そういう入門編の額もそれは全部
皆さんがこれから興味を持つための浅く広い家子なんですね
だからそういうものをそういう視点でこれから先勉強してみては
どうでしょうか
ところで
皆さんこのことがあ
ご存知でしょうか
天は人の上に人を造らず人の下に人を造らずと言う
もちろんこの人の言葉です
我らは福沢諭吉先生
この言葉って6ガンを
てよ say
だったんですけどもグリが慶応生だったんであんまり実はよくわかってなかったんです
か本当の良い見て皆さんご存知でしょうか
よく勘違いされやすいのですね人を差別してはいけませんよて気になっちゃう
いう風に
思われている方も多いですけど実はそういう意味じゃないですね
これはですね
人間は生まれながらにして平等なんだからスタート時点がみんな一緒なんだといっしょ
なんのに世の中にはまあお金持ちの人がいたり
そうでない人がいるまあいろんな差が生まれてくる性が入っ
それは何でなのかそれはなぜかというとパクもしかしたら将来大
人減少あきる野
学問なんですよだから皆さん勉強した方がいいんですよ
っていう意味なんですよだからたく問のススメなんですよねそういうことですん
慶応生にに言いたいとそれを知らない人がっ
コーヒーなんかもう当たり前すぎちゃって
それについて考えることが意外とないんですよね
僕もわかってない曲ってなんです当時車
僕はですねその映画を作ることで映画を作る面白さをしたんと同時にもっと大事な視点
を手に入れサンス同時
それはこのモノやサービスというのは人の手で作られているんだっていうことですね
それを映画を作った僕で映画ってまあそうやっぱり当たり前だけど一つ4つ来られたら
ティ
いうことをしたっていうことは今この手元にあるマイクもそこにあるパソコンも照明も
皆さんがつく
使っている椅子やつ作れもそのマックもどっかで誰かが
フローしながら作ったものなんです
誰かの手によって必ずものは作られてるし
このサービステープとてレックスという仕組みも誰か苦労して作ったものなんです
それをしたときにもなんか何か開けていますあまりにもアタリ当たり前すぎて多分
皆さん考えたことなかったなんか知ってはいるけど実感したことはなかったんじゃない
かなと思うんですけども
僕は映画をつくってそれを
今まで当たり前すぎて考えたことなかったけどもなんか福井付パック
実家のしたんそれを深く理解してですこれは全部のままだ
人の手によって作られているんだということ
だから僕はそこからですねそれまでは母年とかかかっても説明書案の未来男だったん
ですけどもそこからもじっくり説明傷病名だろうとございました
カップのでもスターズ3分間しっかりいっ
測りますそれは満足なのかっていうとそれを作った人が重いだからなんですね
3分間で食べるように作られてい
3分間で食べろって思って作った人がいるんだ
それが最高にその数商品が彼がイク瞬間の
って1本ようになりちょっとアホっくさいかもしれないですけども
説明書を必ず読むようになり
物事は手順は守るより
ていましたん
まあそんな感じなんですで
今僕がこういうふうに提示した視点でですね
世の中自分の周りを見渡してみてください
自分の好きな音って意外と見つけるの難しいです
自分の巣半径3メートル以内をまず
見てみてください意外とそういうところにぽろっと落ちているのかもしれない
自分がどんな仕事をしたいか自分が将来どんなに出たいと言うかそんなことを意識し
ながら今日僕がこういうふうに提供した
提示した視点を持って勉強してみたらどうでしょうか
では
もしそんな風にして
これだって思うでやったらどうすればいいのかっていう話ですね
もしこれだと思う出会えたそれはとても幸せなことですけれども
重いだからって即なれるわけではないしなれるかどうか保証のもちろんないわけです
そこからのは自分次第です映画監督にどういったなるんですかってよく聞かれるんです
けども
映画監督なり方に一つの方法はないですマニュアルみたいなたいですそれは霊感とか
だけじゃなくて他のどんな仕事においても言えるので僕は今どうやってやればいいです
かって言って答えることができないんです
ただそれに近づくための
方法考え方をアドバイスすることでいいんだから僕が映画監督にどうやってなっていい
ですかって聞かれたらこういうふうに答えました
成人漫画の主人公になると
これはどういうことかというとですね
その1
声に出して言ってみましょうもしこれだ
私はこういうことがやりたい
こういう風になりたいって思うことが見つかったらですねそれを他の人に言いまくり
ましょう
お父さんお母さんはもちろん友達にもいいます
道歩いてる人に言ってもいいです
とにかく言って言っていいまというでもそんなことしたら
もしそれが実現できなかったら恥ずかしいじゃん
もし明日みんな思ってるかもしれないんですけども確かにちょっと恥ずかしい
ちょっと恥ずかしいがそれを咎めたり笑ったりするような人はいないです
僕の経験所
別にあの自分がちょっと残念だだけであって
しかもそんな風に登板の女だからって別に大した問題じゃないしそれよりは
言っていって言いまくりましょうそうすると自分のプレッシャーになります
やらなければと言ったからにはやらなきゃだ
そして情報の集まってきます
ある君そういうことをやりたいそれが言ってなかったけ親戚の食べそれがさみたいな
情報が集まってきたい
いろんなところから話が来たりすると思います
とにかく言って言って他の人にスタイルこれはとても重要なことです
その2
いい恋愛しましょう
自分がやりたいことってのは大抵の版一人では実現することができません
誰かなんかの集めました
同じ石同じ夢を持った
それと一緒に
いろんな話をしましょう ed をしてそのつながりを大切にしましょう
この人があって思う人がいた
自分から食らいついていきましょう絶対てお話していきません
意外とチャンスを握ってたり自分の命52点のは自分じゃないですこれ漫画の原作から
出ていく言葉でもあるんですけど
自分だけの実現匹敵ないことが多いですその3
情報を集めましょうそれに対する情報をとにかくあらゆる手段で集めます
手を抜いちゃいけませんどんなことでもいいが情報タイプアンテナを張りましょう
でアンテナを張ってそこにはチャンスが転がってたりもします
まあそういうことさっきみたいに誰それがさーん
やってるんだよなって話それはもうチャンスですだからそこをつかみにいきます
情報を集めましたそれがその3です
その4
貪欲になりましょう自分をとにかく高めています
自分の価値をどんどん高めてくださいなんで自分じゃなきゃいけないか人にプレゼン
できるようになってください
セルフプロデュースをしますどうして自分どうやったら自分がよく見えるかよく見える
か食べなくて実際よくなれるとっていうことも含めて
とにかくとにかく自分の技術的向上
もう目指しましょう
チャンスというのは本当に誰かからピンチな時初めて訪れますその時にそこにいられる
かどうかが
かいいですピンチヒッターとしてその場に居られる方のか
ピンチヒッターにふさわしいになりまし
その後これが一番
大事ですこれまでもその1からその湯を足しても敵わないぐらいこの35が一番大事
です
それは
こういうことです
諦めないということです
あきらめたら本当にそこで終わりです絶対にそれに当たりません
宝くじがー
川之江人には当たらないのと同じことです
やっぱりそこで止めたらその道はとないと思ってくださいん
そうは言っても今言ってはいけないですけど超難しいです
飽きられないと
諦めろって思わせるような出来事がたくさん起きます
本当になんでこんなに虐める理由っていうくらい
でもそこで諦めたらやっぱり終わりなんです
奇跡的な出来事例えば映画監督になるなんていうのはあんま
結構ところないというか何かその分言い始めた時はバカなんじゃないかって思われたり
した
言われたりしたんですけど
なんというかして奇跡っていうのはやっぱりや最後までクライスついたものにしか
起こらないですね
ありに起こるとしたらその最後に食らいついた頃最後まで食らいついた
ものにだけなんですね
諦めないっていうことが一番大事ですすごく難しいですけどね
今日の花車
今勉強すべきな理由は分かったでしょうか
ありがとうございました